gomez - rear back welcome back to
another episode of prepping props and
come here come on come on I have an
awesome plan what's that it's really
okay miss thang I want to you hurry up
no that's the wrong one come here come
to the corridor the long corridor the
hell are you guys hey right here where
maybe yeah okay boonies oh my come here
hug me first okay I'll pick this the
phosphate stop no okay what the [ __ ]
Mack up stuff I'm just kidding like I
was over there yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] okay right
one oh you beauty no no we're poor Dee
oh my god JC is negated scene
Hey so you he totally so you what are
you doing there
nothing are you choose an object go and
choose a cop
I don't think he sees me see me where is
he he's behind a spy I'll find him
earlier
I don't know worries that come on let's
please stop their eyes
I could smell him I know he's somewhere
near here don't know where he's at
find him one day what he's not in the
shed hey evil odo
a b'doop oh you have been duped as well
they seriously that was inside the lamp
shade tell me where the other thing
quickly they'll be fine
I hate when the lamps run hey really
quiet but I think you're still throw if
you like
sure he can he didn't this what the [ __ ]
really what what where what what I don't
get it so much hate right now no he
would totally be fine stiff oh wait what
this visit this one no it's that you see
okay okay
where did he go I wonder why that's so
weird
which one did me he's actually in that
he's not in here he's in the very room
he's totally no really her butt huh how
did you not see that max TASIS what I
guess I'll just have killer one I'm not
gonna let this one escape top movement
you're not going anywhere
what makes what we doing I make sure it
isn't me I was visualizing the map if
you say something nice about us we'll
let you live oh okay
he disappeared how weird yeah Oh sixty I
don't know I just have an inborn talent
have my ways you can blog it I am about
I promise you on the barrel okay
yo are you in the batter room possibly
not yeah didn't think so
yeah all right this is a barrel she's a
you found it didn't you feel like
[Laughter]
killing it's me I have no health it's
just [ __ ] come on max just do it your
turn to waste
oh [ __ ] I'm stop max 30 seconds your
hands can't head kill it I press hope
you enjoyed this episode I know it was a
little shorter than normal but it's only
as much as I can do every single thing
so hope you bros understand and I don't
have to read watch this video show short
and if you calm it down already you
should feel bad anyway thousand brothers
love you it interest dudes and I shot
the wrong guy
[Music]
yes